ja kommt bei dieser als sonst hey leute
ich hab nicht mal zusammen mit diesen
werten menschen ihr date die regie und
hinter der kamera sebastiani im urlaub
und die werden schon titel gelesen haben
ist es weg wir haben unter wasser gesund
und wir werden jetzt schauen ob wir
raten können was die jeweils andere
gesungen
das habe ich schon mal gemacht es sehr
lustig gebäuden wisst ihr das mega geld
ist es das mikrofon nicht angeschlossen
ist berlin
alles natürlich wieder damit mikrofon
dave der techniker ein anderes gericht
habe das ja schon mal gemacht wie ich
halte und es hat einfach dsds geklaut
die multitronic persönlich stand auch an
sebastians titel aber ist aber lasst uns
weiter rum reden wir fangen einfach an
als erstes hat
sobald jemand etwas weiß einfach rein
rufen ausläuft
[Musik]
august in köln kein problem kaputter
budget mich aufgezogen aber nicht
wahllos auf den titel sei es aber ich
habe hier antworten über einen punkt für
mich kein ziel das wird für mich okay
nächste runde durch und ist wie gesagt
ist einziger wirt gemacht und redet
kriegt davon 17 ähnlich weil es mir zu
anstrengend ist ein einschnitt
irgendjemand wird vielleicht hatte ich
habe so ein bisschen blacks klassische
school
[Musik]
mittlerweile glaube ich noch mal wir
können ganz gut zu überreden die fakten
klar das wasser dann weißt du nicht was
auch schön auf unsere häuser schützt
also doch mal rein
[Musik]
ich habe selbst wieder erkranken
okay waren zudem zeigt wie hugh grant
ist aufgestanden wird schotter ist meine
mama etwas war ich würde gern einfach
schwarz nebenrolle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das würde auch einfach sagen außer rot
teilweises megastädte wir müssen darauf
achten leute ich zeige es mal wieder so
aus als hätte man gemachte lippen wenn
man diese
ich hab keine aber kennst du den song
nicht von selbst mit gesang anlass jetzt
super wichtig gerade das date hat auf
seinem kanal ein krasses videoprojekt
gelangt wo er sich in einer woche das
tätowieren beigebracht hat und sich
nebenbei selbst kommt er zu töten wir
sehen wollen
[Musik]
keine ahnung ich weiß wie ich glaube ich
sagt einfach das beste smartphone
kapitalplan 0 im wembley
[Musik]
er gehört dem vorstand unter wasser als
wäre nichts ohne bus tech datas auch
noch der vulkan aber nicht mehr halten
bewegung wieder rap beschreiben was
superschnell ist auf jedem der das war
keine schande aber ich glaube ich dass
was würde ich sagen das ist ja ich weiß
es nicht
die zustand ist mit rad wenn doch
scheint senica verratet du wirst deinen
sondern ich weiß aber nicht
das war unser offizieller website auf
dauerschleife wird oder ja eigentlich
hätte es jeder erwartet so schnell
ersichtlich geworden
aktuell führe ich 18 20 ich lege schon
wieder hell eingeflogen
im moment hast du ja ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich gedacht habe ich habe keine
ahnung was das ist ist es sehr gut dass
wir hier mehr als 50 prozent der songs
nicht einmal selber wieder erkenne bei
einem anderen video war das viel besser
wir sind einfach schlecht da ich weiß
welches land es ist immer schwer
portofino wollen wir noch einmal an
aber was ist das schon
doch trainer zählt das herzlichste
kennen natürlich den zorn aber ich habe
mit dem titel habe ich gewusst dass ich
wusste das auch nur aus zufall nicht
mehr überhören
die neue intel aber was ich gefühlt dass
diese ganze musik von europa zum horn
gibt also wenn ihr mit mir führte dann
bittet okay im extra ich meine eltern
[Musik]
das so klar wie alles verliert aber
roger hat das habe ich sowieso pause
belieben ist man hat sich dann beide
wasser im mund hat ist
viel haben wir anlass
wenn ich noch mal wieder ein land in dem
das land in den mund singt das wird auch
die gegner halten verkaufsnummer hatte
ja wir nehmen dieses video gerade nach
acht stunden autofahrt auf soll dass ich
trotzdem dabei sein
ja ich kann ich klatschen das nicht
durchkämmt hat es nie gelernt
[Musik]
ich habe ich habe dafür keine luft
bekommen ich habe mich gesund also dann
hört das auf
das von vier songs bereits beim casting
nicht gesund
[Applaus]
beim video dabei offiziell bestes video
und ich sind jetzt schon mehr als bisher
können das war sehr positiv
aber ich weiß dass ich recht gut
aber auch die ersten anfragen vor allem
das ende hat es war ein zwei große beim
ersten mal an und direkte kann ja jeder
kopfstimme einfach denn ich muss mich
sagen ich glaube was gemacht werden
sondern als mittel des fonds aber du
hast quasi geworden sagte sodann ging es
doch um zu gewinnen
[Musik]
dieses gesagt das ist doch ein solches
gerät die alles entscheiden wir jetzt
gewinnt hier will ich nichts gefunden
und heutigen zeit habe ich auch immer du
hast nur du hast meinen andere leute
schauen wir direkt aus dem unterricht
fiel dann leuchtet es dabei sein wie man
es auch irgendwann sehen